-Welcome back to "The Tonight Show."
We're about to play a game called "Box of Lies."
But I'm gonna need some help. She stars in "Stranger Things."
Season 4 premieres May 27th on Netflix.
Please welcome Millie Bobby Brown!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, now. Come on!
Are you kidding me? Come on. It's so good to see you.
I miss you. -Good to see you, too!
-Millie, here's how it works.
We have nine mystery boxes containing objects
no one has ever seen before. Okay?
On your turn, you pick a box, take out the object,
and describe it to your opponent.
-Can I sit down? -Yes, please.
-Oh, my, I'm -- You're not even ready for this.
-No. Really? -No.
-You have to describe what's in the box, put it out there,
and then I and you decide if we're telling the truth.
I can't even look at you. Or if we're lying.
Okay? -Alright.
-Are you already playing right now?
I'm in your head right now.
-I don't even know if you know what I'm thinking right now.
-Yeah, I totally do. You have no clue.
Are you ready to go first?
-Oh, my God. -That's the way I talk.
That's the way I talk to you. -That was berating me.
-It was, right? All right, bud, you're up first.
You can pick the first box. -Alright.
-Which one? -Four!
-Four.
-He was so passionate about four.
-Yeah, he was very passionate about four.
-Alright. [ Audience shouting ]
-This could be a hint right here.
-Oh, my gosh! -Yeah.
It looked like it was a little light.
-No, I've just got huge guns.
[ Laughter ] Huge guns.
-Huge guns. Alright, bud. -Okay.
-Yep. [ Clears throat ]
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. -Alright.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
-The music. Alright. Jimmy.
-Mm-hmm.
-Um, this almost looks like
a children's play set kind of.
You know? Something that a child would play with.
And it's the Demogorgon from the show,
a toy Demogorgon, painting E.T.
-A children's play set. -Yep.
Yep.
-What does that mean again? -I don't know.
It's up for interpretation.
-Children's play set.
-And It's painting E.T. with my eyeshadow palette
from Florence by Mills.
-Ah! Now, I know -- I love Florence.
-Yes. -I know your makeup line, yes.
-And, um, that's what he's doing.
With a makeup brush.
-E.T. Yep. Uh-huh.
E.T.. And you've seen the movie "E.T."
-Um, I don't know. Have I?
-You're very young.
-Am I?
[ Laughter ]
-No, I actually know how old you are.
Yes, you are young. But you've seen "E.T." before.
You loved it?
-Loved it. -Yeah.
What character did you love in "E.T."?
-E.T. himself. -Yeah, I know, but there's
other characters in there. How about the boy?
-I loved the boy. -Yeah. What was his name?
-Elliott. -Hmm.
You do know "E.T."
-Or do I?
Did I just read a synopsis before I came out here?
-So you have a child's play set, is what threw me.
That makes no sense to me, 'cause a child's play set --
-Well, do you have children, Jimmy?
-Yes. They don't have play sets.
-They don't have toys? -They don't have toys.
-They're not real. -Toys are banned from the house.
Toys are banned from the house. Only books.
A child play set to me seems like a swing set or something.
That's a play set.
-No. I mean like a toy almost.
You know, something that you go, "Oy, oy!"
You know?
-Yeah, a toy and a painting of a Demogorgon, E.T.
Too many details.
I'm going to say, Millie Bobby Brown, you lie!
-Owwww. -Oh, my gosh!
Are you kidding me?
[ Sad tuba plays ]
Come on. You're good. You know how to act.
Come on. What am I talking about?
Why mess with the best?
Why mess with the best? I'm sorry.
Of course you're going to be a good actor.
Which one, guys?
[ Audience shouting ]
-I'm going to put -- My "E.T." for later.
I'm going to put it this way.
-[ Grunts ] -I'm here with you.
-Okay. Alright. Here we go.
Phew.
Mm-hmm.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
-Uh-huh. -Oh, my goodness.
-[ Mocking laughter ]
Go! Tell me!
-It is --
It's, like, a child's play set.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
It is a bowl.
Full of Chef Boyardee.
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know how to describe it. Pasta.
-Okay.
-Yeah, it's a bowl of Chef -- I should have said that.
But it's Chef Boyardee, 'cause the can is next to it.
It's a canned food in America.
-Oh, okay. I'm from England.
-Sorry. You're from England. Yes.
-Yeah. -Yes, and in that bowl
is a head that looks to me like Elon Musk.
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk head in the Chef Boyardee.
So it's like pasta with Elon Musk's head.
-Okay. -Heads.
-Heads? -Yes.
It's, like, floating. -Multiple different heads?
-Floating like -- -How many?
-Four. -Four.
I know you are lying.
-How?
-'Cause you're a horrible liar.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you talking about? Are you sure?
-I'm positive. I don't want to ask any more questions.
I know that you're lying.
-No, no, no, ask me -- -No, I -- Okay, fine.
Fine, fine! I'll ask you one more question.
What shape pasta is it, Jimmy?
-I was lying! You won! You knew!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's spaghetti and meatballs. Baseballs.
I thought maybe you could smell the pasta,
so then I started trying to make something up.
And I messed up. -You got nervous.
You got really nervous. -I did, right?
-As soon -- You know what -- Just for future reference.
It's when -- I just want to make you --
As soon as I asked how many heads,
you just went straight for four. -Oh.
-When you just should have taken one more look
at how many Elon Musk heads were in that bowl.
-Yeah, yeah, exactly. I could really count four.
-Well, anyways. -But I knew four.
-It's my turn now. -Yes, it's your turn. Yes.
[ Audience shouting ]
Someone's saying eight. Five is the one. Okay.
[ Thud ]
-Did that scare you? -Yeah, it did a little bit.
It woke me up. Okay, here we go.
-Alright!
-Okay, 'cause the first one was not a lie.
So I figure, well, maybe this one
you're gonna probably think of something.
Or the pressure's on. Your face is getting red.
So you're probably thinking -- -It's just my blush.
[ Giggles ]
♪♪
Okay. -Mm-hmm.
-It is... -Uh-huh.
-...a Croc, sandal kind of shoe.
-I know what a Croc is. -I don't know.
You didn't know what a children's play set was, so...
-Yeah, I'm sorry. Thank you.
-Stuffed with pasta. Spaghetti pasta.
Cooked.
And it's going through the holes of the Croc.
-Mm-hmm. Huh.
-And there's a watermelon-flavored
Sour Patch Kid in --
drowning, really, in the spaghetti.
-Now, how would you know it's watermelon-flavored?
-Because they're green on the bottom.
And they're one of my favorites, actually.
I eat them on set quite -- -How do you see the bottom
if he's drowning in the -- -No, I see it.
I can see it from the top.
From the top angle, I see it's green.
-Okay.
-And also spaghetti is quite, you know, thin,
so I can see through the spaghetti.
-Oh, I know spaghetti, 'cause I was just lying about it.
-I know. I know. -Yeah.
So you're saying two spaghettis?
That's -- What are the odds of choosing two spaghettis?
-I don't know. Ask your writers.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Oh, you're good. Oh, you're good.
[ Applause ] Oh, you're good.
♪♪
I'm gonna say...
you're telling the truth!
♪♪
[ Sad tuba plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh! You're so good! You're so good!
Wait. Can I try? One more?
-One more. -Yeah, here we go.
[ Audience shouting ] -Three, Jimmy!
-That's my man three right there.
Yeah, look. So light. Oh, my gosh.
It's like there's nothing in it.
-[ Laughs ] -But there might be.
Who knows?
-You're so red. -Oh, my goodness.
It's just awesome.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
You ready to get into this world?
-I don't know. Am I?
-I mean my brain.
-Oh, yeah. -Yeah.
See what I saw? Do you want to see?
Maybe I'll take my time a little bit on this one.
-Alright. [ Laughs ]
-Is my acting getting better?
-No.
-It's a, uh -- baseball hat.
-Mm.
-But one that holds the drinks.
♪♪
And one drink -- You know those people that have beers --
-No. I've never been to a baseball game.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Is it where they drink the beer through straws?
-Yes!
One -- Instead of beer, though, one is Pepto Bismol.
And one is...
[ Laughter ]
One is...
Hmm. What is that?
[ Laughter ]
I learn from the best, bud.
One is, uh, hot sauce.
-What kind?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I'm not wearing my glasses, of course,
but I can tell by the bottle that it's Sriracha.
-Oh. Sriracha mayo or just regular Sriracha?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Regular Sriracha. -Uh-huh.
This is what I'm going to say.
I'm gonna say it is a partial lie.
I think you are telling the truth in some places,
but I think that I've got you on this hat.
I don't think it's this kind of hat.
You've accepted my suggestion far too quickly.
I don't believe that it's one of those beer hats.
-Yeah. How could it be? -I don't know.
You tell me! -That's the game.
So you have to make the choice.
-You lie! -You think I lie?
Oh, I tell the truth.
-No! -Yes!
Redeemed myself! I redeemed myself!
Millie Bobby Brown, everybody! [ Laughs ] I'm so happy.
I redeemed myself. -You did so good!
-I did. I learned. I learned from the best.
We're talking to Millie after the break. Stick around.